ein besten angriff hat es gegeben auf
kinder auf einem schulhof 14 verletzte
jörg steinberg ist bei mir jetzt im
studio jörg welche informationen haben
wir da genau das hört sich ja sehr
schlimm an 14 verletzte kinder durch
wespen was weißt du mehr
er muss erst einmal sagen 14 verletzte
die feuerwehr die dort eingegriffen hat
seit die kinder sind nicht schwer
verletzt aber die symptome gehen über
ein normaler symptome eines westen
schießt deutlich hinaus also da scheint
einiges passiert zu sein was passiert
ist heute morgen ungefähr viertel vor
elf stand auf eine schülergruppe auf dem
schulhof einer gesamtschule in
lüdenscheid und wurde angegriffen von
einem schwarm wilder westen was eine
sehr ungewöhnliche geschichte ist kommt
eigentlich selten vor auf mal gibt es
ein wespennest hat die feuerwehr
gefunden in der nähe der schule und sind
mindestens 14 schüler verletzt die auch
alle in umliegende krankenhäuser
gebracht werden also sah recht
bedrohlich aus auf dem schulhof sind
mehrere notarzt wagen gekommen
die feuerwehr ist gekommen kann man
jetzt noch nicht ganz übersehen wie
viele verletzte es am ende sein werden
was mit den schülern ist ob die am ende
des tages nach hause gehen können ob es
da vielleicht noch schlimmere symptome
gibt das ist alles noch moment unklar
unser reporter ist auf dem weg und wird
uns sicherlich in kürze mehr erzählen
können aber es ist ein wespennest hat
man schon gefunden und damit die ursache
eigentlich geklärt
ja es ist nur nicht ganz klar wo es
genau gewesen ist ob das jetzt auf dem
schulgelände gewesen ist oder direkt
daneben gewesen ist jetzt ein wespennest
ja auch noch nicht so wahnsinnig
ungewöhnlich die gibt es ja gibt es ja
viele aber dass die westen dann so
aggressiv eine gruppe von schülern
angreifen das ist sehr ungewöhnlich